bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de dimanche en politique cette
semaine je reçois le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire premier vice-président du
MoDem Marc féno bonjour soyez le
bienvenu deux agriculteurs de la région
vous poseront également des questions
Nicolas bête sans Dupleix de
Saint-Germain-des-Prés dans le Loiret
bonjour monsieur et Philippe Bruno
éleveur en Touraine bonjour
on découvre et puis il y aura également
Jean-Yves Chauveau qui est journaliste à
terre de Touraine il nous parlera lui de
la transition écologique Marc fenon
découvre votre bio Express vous avez 51
ans ministre de la de l'agriculture
depuis cet été après avoir été pendant
quatre ans ministre des Relations avec
le Parlement vice-président du MoDem je
le disais et conseiller régional ici en
centre Val de Loire on va tout de suite
entrer dans le vif du sujet car
l'actualité est fournie premier dossier
les ressources en eau et les cultures
alors en ce qui concerne les ressources
on nous on va évidemment tout de suite
parler des méga bassines marqueno c'est
réserves d'eau gigantesques à ciel
ouvert qui servent à l'irrigation leur
installation est très polémique les
écologistes ils sont fermement opposés
comment est-ce que vous positionnez sur
le sujet et ce qu'il faut malgré tout
les développer on a besoin de développer
des réserves d'eau alors je sais pas ce
que c'est que le terme méga une dizaine
d'hectares de surfaces en eau c'est ce
qu'on a d'ailleurs les étangs de Sologne
pour un certain nombre de surfaces on
s'est volumes là donc on dit pas que
c'est des méga étant on dit que c'est
des étangs mais en tout cas sur le fond
je me positionne sur l'idée que dans un
cycle de l'eau qui change qu'est-ce qui
change c'est que il y a des mois sans
eau et des mois au pluriel
parfois deux trois quatre mois sans eau
quasiment sans eau et puis le meilleur
des périodes on a connu ça cette année
par ailleurs des périodes où il y a
beaucoup plus d'eau et que donc on a
besoin de retrouver ce cycle en captant
l'eau en supplément qui tombe l'hiver
pour la restituer l'été parce que sinon
il y aura pas d'agriculture une
meilleure gestion meilleure gestion
pourquoi je dis ça parce que le GIEC
dans ces travaux de sur le dérèglement
climatique qu'est-ce qu'il dit il dit
qu'en gros la quantité d'eau qui va
tomber va être la même seule difficulté
c'est qu'elle va pas tomber au même
moment elle va pas être moins linéaire
donc ça va être arythmique si vous
permettez cette expression donc on a
besoin de la capter dans les périodes où
il y en a beaucoup pour la restituer
dans les périodes où il y en a pas à ce
sujet je salue Philippe Bruno éleveur et
producteur laitiers en Indre-et-Loire et
ancien
ancien président de la literie de
Verneuil vous utilisez vous-même des des
retenus colinéaires comme on les appelle
pour irriguer vous êtes donc favorable
ou projet des bassines alors il est
évident comme l'a dit monsieur le
ministre que il faut retenir cette eau
qui part
nous l'avons fait un groupe
d'agriculteur
sur plusieurs lieux avec des petits
barrages sur des têtes de bassin à un
moment où c'était encore possible et
donc ça ça plein d'intérêt plein de
vertus puisque on va retenir de l'eau à
des moments où il y en a plus rien en
tout cas de la bonne gestion voilà et on
empêche des limons d'aller à la rivière
des excès d'eau d'aller très rapidement
à la rivière dans des petits ballons où
il a été creusé des fossé par
l'administration alors ma question par
rapport à ça c'est que aujourd'hui on ne
peut plus le faire parce que c'est
faussés qui ont été créés dans les
années 60-70 pour l'assainissement
par soutenu par l'administration et
dirigé par l'administration aujourd'hui
j'irai l'administration a mis un trait
bleu sur ses fossés les classants
ruisseaux alors qu'ils ne reçoivent de
l'eau que très peu de journées à l'année
et ce qui empêche administrativement à
faire des réponses c'est issu des
travaux qui ont été Pau il y a très
longtemps sur la loi sur l'eau qui fait
que il y a un certain nombre d'éléments
qui sont interdits alors ça n'obéère pas
toutes les capacités à faire des
retenues colinéaires il faut qu'on
essaie de combiner des choses ça a été
très bien dit à l'instant c'est-à-dire
que les ouvrages ils puissent servir à
l'irrigation et puis servir aussi à
soutenir les étiages il puisse soutenir
parfois les périodes où il y a trop
d'eau c'est-à-dire pour éviter les
inondations il faut qu'on essaie de
cumuler les choses on est en train de
regarder alors d'abord il y a des
projets qui se développent dans ce
territoire alors un peu moins en région
Centre que dans d'autres mais je faisais
la revue de projet qui me permet de ces
expression en région mauvaise
Rhône-Alpes plus de 60 projets qui sont
en cours de réalisation donc c'est bien
possible qu'il faut qu'on essaie de
regarder c'est là où il y a quelques
freins administratifs pour essayer
d'avancer mais en même temps faut le
faire avec une exigence quand même c'est
d'essayer de limiter l'impact sur le
milieu donc c'est là qu'il faut qu'on
essaie de dialoguer
le plus simple encore que la bonne
gestion de bon sens une marque fino je
vous propose maintenant qu'on évoque
l'économie du secteur agricole parce que
là la situation est tendue
[Musique]
on va commencer par le prix de la viande
notamment et le prix de la tonne de lait
qui sont jugés encore beaucoup trop bas
par les éleveurs qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez aujourd'hui alors il y a eu des
efforts de fait il y a eu des lois de
voter des efforts de fait on est dans
une situation particulière c'est la loi
Gallim 2 comme ça qu'elle s'appelle qui
a permis de construire le prix à partir
du prix de la matière première agricole
c'est comme ça qu'on a voulu faire les
choses alors sur la viande bovine on a
plutôt une situation qui est un peu
moins mauvaise que n'était il y a un an
parce que il y a ça a décapitalisé donc
un peu moins de viande présente sur le
marché et donc ça a plutôt eu un effet
de faire monter les prix alors je sais
pas si c'est forcément une bonne
nouvelle d'avoir des capitalisé mais en
tout cas c'est la situation du marché la
difficulté sur la viande bovine comme
sur la viande laitière c'est que par
ailleurs les coups ont augmenté de façon
très significative l'alimentation du
bétail et en particulier sur le lait on
a une situation qui est assez tendue
parce que il y a un certain nombre
d'opérateurs qui n'ont pas assez
répercuté les coûts on sait autour de
500 euros
les 1000 litres on arrive à équilibrer
souvent on est plutôt à 430 440 450 et
il y a un travail à faire alors on a
plutôt progressé dans les derniers mois
mais on est encore un peu loin du compte
et on parlera le temps doute tout à
l'heure des questions de reprise des
exploitations laitières en particulier
il faut qu'on ait une meilleure
rémunération donc ça c'est dans le
dialogue avec les transformateurs puis
aussi avec la grande distribution c'est
que malgré cette crise il s'est
difficulté c'est un secteur qui recrute
notamment parce que equival recruter
parce qu'il va y avoir une bascule de
génération il y a beaucoup
d'agriculteurs qui vont partir là et
puis quand on regarde moi j'étais
l'autre jour en Franche-Comté quand il y
a de la valorisation sur le lait
d'ailleurs la laiterie de Verneuil avait
fait beaucoup d'efforts pour essayer de
trouver un circuit de valorisation en
cherchant des créneaux particuliers le
circuit court de valorisation des
produits locaux avec une image et un
marketing particulier
quand on a de la rémunération on trouve
des jeunes ou des moins jeunes
d'ailleurs qui veulent bien s'installer
donc c'est le facteur clé pour
l'installation effectivement ça a été
votre cas parce que vous il y a pas
tellement longtemps après plus de 40
années de d'exercices vous êtes partis à
la retraite sont vos enfants et votre
jambe qui l'exploitation familiale alors
qu'ils destinait pas du tout à ça ça
s'est bien passé
ils étaient déjà dans dans d'autres
entreprises dans d'autres milieux ils
ont fait le choix de revenir je pense
qu'il y a différentes choses il y a son
entreprise est-ce qu'elle est
actuellement en France on est bien aidé
dans ce secteur agricole c'est compliqué
compliqué parce que
quand on est agriculteur notre souci
c'est qu'on est obligé de capitaliser
énormément pour faire tourner nos
exploitations et donc la fin est très
difficile ce sont des capitaux
importants alors quand c'est dans le
milieu familial on peut trouver des
solutions pour étaler un petit peu tout
ça mais pour je pense des jeunes qui
s'installe hors du cadre familial c'est
évidemment très compliqué parce que les
sommes sont lourdes après
c'est vrai que mes enfants sont sans
doute revenus pour reprendre la ferme
familiale mais aussi parce que on a
changé l'image du producteur on l'a
travaillé beaucoup nos sur une petite
coopérative
parce qu'on est on est attaqué on est
montré du doigt aujourd'hui quand
j'entends j'entends entendu ce matin
quelqu'un dans une université
ou un enseignant a dit aux élèves mais
l'agriculture l'élevage c'est terminé en
France pour des raisons écologiques mais
c'est quand même un raccourci un peu
fort et c'est quand même une production
de produits qui sont
qualitatifs extrêmement extrêmement
je vois une chose puisqu'on parle de
produits de qualité comme la literie de
Verneuil on tombe des produits vraiment
de haute qualité on note une chose c'est
qu'avec cette crise économique avec
l'inflation sont les magasins bio qui
qui connaissent de sacrés difficultés
oui c'est une des formes de la qualité
c'est vrai que le bio en particulier des
rampières laitières parfois c'est une
rémunération qui est du même niveau que
celle du lait conventionnel avec des
risques de déconversion et donc un
risque très puissant parce qu'une fois
quelqu'un s'est déconverti au bureau il
y aura bien grande difficulté à faire
revenir vers le bio
on est en train de travailler on va on
va regarder avec les acteurs de la
filière bio parce que il y a un sujet
conjoncturel c'est-à-dire que les gens
contenus de leur niveau de revenus
contenus de l'inflation dégrade la
nature des produits qui prennent et donc
le bio
étant haut de gamme on descend en gamme
et on le voit dans toutes les secteurs
de la grande distribution et puis un
sujet sans doute un sujet structurel
parce que le bio comment le bio se
positionne entre les circuits courts les
produits sous la belle il y a un sujet
de positionnement sans doute mais ça
c'est une réalité oui c'est une réalité
d'intérieur on parle de la qualité des
produits vous ne connaissez le combat de
Richard rameau sur Supprimer les
nitrites notamment dans les charcuteries
même combat que Richard Ramos pour vous
le combat il est simple
ni Richard Ramos ni moi ne sommes des
scientifiques c'est de se baser sur ce
que dit la science et en particulier
d'ailleurs c'est ce qui avait demandé
Richard Ramos a juste titre c'est
d'avoir un rapport de lands
qui a donné un certain nombre de
préconisations qui a dit plusieurs
choses qui étaient d'abord la quantité
journalière de nitrite qui était
utilisée et puis de qui était consommé
pardon et deuxièmement de regarder là où
partout il y a des alternatives
d'essayer de tendre vers moins de
nitrites ou 0 nitrite donc on est en
train de travailler un plan d'action qui
va se conformer strictement à ce que dit
l'ancêtre je pense que c'est bien de se
baser sur la science c'est une fois que
la science a dit des choses qu'on essaie
de ce conformer à ce qui nous disent en
terme de
d'orientation
qui donne des avis sur bien des sujets
en termes d'alimentation et donc je
souhaite qu'on puisse aller dans le sens
de ce qu'ils disent permettrait de dire
un mot sur ce qui vient de dire sur la
question de l'élevage on a besoin
d'élevage en France il y a des il y a
des il y a des tendances choses qui sont
une diminution de la consommation de
viande c'est pas en soins une difficulté
si jamais il y a la rémunération vous si
on peut mieux valoriser oui évidemment
les produits de qualité le jour qui sont
faits en France donc c'est pas faut pas
avoir peur de cette diminution
tendancielle parce que c'est une des
structurelles cette diminution de
consommation de viande mais il faut
défendre l'élevage parce qu'on a besoin
parce que ils tiennent le territoire une
partie de nos pays une partie de la
qualité de la biodiversité une partie de
la transition des engrais minéraux vers
les engrais organiques elle vient vers
l'élevage on a besoin de l'élevage et
donc ceux qui disent il suffit il y a
qu'un faucon ce qui est quand même un
truc qui traîne beaucoup supprimer
l'élevage pour régler les problèmes je
pense qu'on aurait bien plus de
problèmes si on n'avait pas d'élevage
cette position merci en tout cas
Philippe Bruno pour vous témoignages
venons-en maintenant si vous le voulez
bien à nos habitudes de consommation car
elles ont un réel impact sur l'économie
agricole et les productions
avec un constat une évidence c'est que
les Français mangent de moins en moins
de viande c'est un nouvel handicap qui
fait baisser forcément il y a une action
mécanique sur la production d'année en
année est-ce que cette filière oui j'ai
l'impression avec ce que vous venez dire
cette filière a toujours de l'avenir
cette filière à l'avenir elle a de
l'avenir sous la réserve qu'on essaie de
l'accompagner dans les grandes
transitions qui sont à l'oeuvre en
particulier la capacité à décarboner ces
filières là et deux de trouver un lien
peut-être plus plus fort avec les
filières grandes cultures en particulier
sur la question de l'apport en anglais
organique peut apporter ses filières et
puis cette Hilaire à l'avenir d'autant
plus que il y a des marchés extérieurs
qui peuvent s'ouvrir je pense au port et
puis on a de la reconquête de
souveraineté à faire je pense à la
volaille 50% de la volaille que nous
consommons en France vient de
l'extérieur de l'extérieur et vient pas
loin elle vient d'Europe et donc on a un
travail à faire ne serait-ce que cette
reconquête de souveraineté y compris
dans une tendance lourde qui serait une
tendance de baisse permettra un nombre
d'éleveurs de retrouver de la
rémunération donc je pense
et ce d'autant que dans beaucoup de
territoires elle est la seule activité
qui peut se développer l'élevage c'est
un dossier qui a du sens et donc c'est
un dossier qui a du sens l'agriculture
est soumise elle aussi de aux décisions
politiques agriculteurs et responsable
politique femme forme d'un atelage pas
toujours très serein
[Musique]
mars
International de l'Agriculture approche
ça sera au mois de février c'est souvent
cette occasion que le monde agricole se
fait entendre et revendique est-ce qu'à
cette période vous aurez des des
annonces particulières à leur faire
alors la question c'est pas de faire de
grandes annonces les annonces efficaces
c'est de faire des annonces efficaces le
président de la République est venu à
toute occasion au Salon de l'Agriculture
pour annoncer un certain nombre de
choses puis prendre aussi la température
lui aussi il est un peu comme Monsieur
Chirac il apprécie beaucoup il apprécie
beaucoup le à la fois le salon de
l'agriculture mais le contact avec le
monde agricole c'est un monde qui
connaît bien et donc qui soit perçoit
bien à la fois les attentes et les
ressort si je peux dire des choses ainsi
et donc le cerve de l'agriculture c'est
l'occasion d'avoir une rencontre entre
le monde agricole et les citoyens parce
que c'est un salon qui est à Paris
les principaux visiteurs sont quand même
des urbains et donc c'est bien de
montrer ça et puis deuxième élément
c'est l'occasion de faire le point et de
regarder c'est par exemple dans ce cadre
là que le Président de la République a
pu faire des annonces sur la question
des gamines a pu faire des annonces sur
la question du système d'assurance a pu
faire des annonces sur la question d'une
grande loi sur le renouvellement des
générations après ce qu'il avait dû déjà
des annonces comme traditionnellement
traditionnellement c'est plutôt le chef
de l'exécutif c'est le président de la
République c'est donc normal que ça
celui qui fasse et après c'est nous on a
un travail à faire comme ministre de
l'agriculture en l'occurrence donc
et puis après que les choses se
déroulent parce que le Président de la
République est très vigilant aussi à ce
que les annonces étant pesées sous
pesées et puis après se mettre en oeuvre
secteur agricole plan lui aussi
malheureusement de plein fouet la crise
énergétique ça aussi c'est un dossier
qui est extrêmement préoccupant on y va
[Musique]
à ce propos on va accueillir Nicolas
bête ce qui nous rejoint sur Skype
bonjour Nicolas best vous êtes
exploitant agricole avec vos frères à
Saint-Germain-des-Prés c'est dans le
Loiret à vous faites culture élevage de
porc vache laitière vous avez vu les
différents coups aux commentaires
énergie et aussi intrant c'est dans
quelle proportion pour vous dans votre
exploitation
bonjour à tous bonjour monsieur le
ministre bonjour
des proportions inquiétantes
on a
2022 sachets je dirais où nous avions
encore nos contrats d'achat de matière
qui avait été fait en 2021 donc je
dirais qu'on a aujourd'hui entre
guillemets supporter supporter quelques
hausses mais le pire reste à venir pour
nous notamment sur le domaine
énergétique or une exploitation laitière
n'est pas la plus grande consommatrice
en énergie hormis la réfrigération du
lait évidemment mais en fait là où on le
sent c'est évidemment dans dans le coup
de nos intrants l'aliment l'aliment pour
les bovins l'aliment pour les vaches
laitières ou on va poser vous savez on
va poser la question tout de suite à
Marc PHENO qu'est-ce que vous avez
adopté qu'est-ce que vous adopterez
vraisemblablement pour aider ces
exploitants agricoles qui alors là pour
le coup effectivement sont souvent sont
des exploitations très énergivores
électricité gasoil comment l'énergie
c'est partout au fond c'est ce qui vient
d'être dit parce que les engrais c'est
de l'énergie
l'alimentation c'est de l'énergie en
partie au-delà de ce dont on a besoin
pour réfrigérer et autres à plusieurs il
y a plusieurs plusieurs sujets le
premier sujet qu'on a posé sur la table
c'est près de 500 millions qui ont été
mis en aide peut-être que monsieur a pu
en bénéficier c'est un plan d'aide à
l'alimentation animale qui a été
déployée
qui est en cours de finalisation de
paiement pour favoriser le fait que les
éleveurs aient accès à une alimentation
animale des cours qui soit moins élevés
donc ça c'est la première chose deuxième
chose sur lequel on travaille alors pour
le coup là ça n'est pas encore abouti
sur c'est vrai que monsieur a raison de
ça c'était le premier mur le deuxième
mur qu'on a c'est le mur énergétique
c'est à dire les factures qui arrivent
le renouvellement des contrats qui
peuvent paraître être à mur énergétique
on est en train d'ajuster un dispositif
qui soit un dispositif d'amortissement
un peu de ce coup et de par un système
d'aide déclencher
selon la dépendance ça ressemble à
l'énergie pour les agripper c'est plutôt
un système d'aide de là il y a un
bouquet tarifaire pour les moins de 36
kg mais la plupart des agriculteurs sont
au dessus donc c'est en tout cas des
systèmes comme cela sont au dessus donc
une bénéficient pas du bouquetaires qui
peut bénéficier au plus petites
structure pour les autres c'est plutôt
un système d'aide qu'on est en train
d'affiner parce que reconnaissance que
le système qu'on avait posé cet été
c'était pas tout à fait ajusté adapté au
monde agricole on a un frein je veux pas
rentrer dans les détails mais on a un
frein qui est la question de de la
dépendance à l'énergie la part de
l'énergie dans le chiffre d'affaires et
sans doute que c'est sur ce levier là
qu'il faut bouger pour pouvoir mieux
aider les agriculteurs on peut évoquer
également dans les solutions les
énergies alternatives et on pourrait
facilement on pourrait d'ailleurs se
demander si elles sont suffisamment
utilisées en agriculture Nicolas Besse
dites-moi vous avez justement vous un
méthaniseur qui produit donc une énergie
renouvelable du gaz à partir de bio
déchets alors ça marche mais vous dites
qu'on vous met des bâtons dans les roues
pourquoi ça
alors je reviens un petit mot
effectivement on a bénéficié de l'aide
mise en place par l'État bon 500
millions d'euros c'est une somme énorme
mais répondu sur l'ensemble de des
agriculteurs ça reste un film et
insuffisant pour couvrir la hausse de du
coup de l'aliment parlez-nous de
l'énergie ne renouvelables très
rapidement s'il vous plaît parce qu'il
nous reste peu de temps pourquoi vous
mettez dans les roues alors nous avons
déjà nous avons en place une unité de
méthanisation qui est qui existe depuis
2008 et elle c'est de la cogénération
c'était une des premières en France
aujourd'hui nous portons un projet pour
développer une nouvelle unité cette fois
pour injecter du gaz dans le réseau GrDF
le projet est en route depuis 2019
nous avons eu l'acceptation d'un permis
de construire nous attendons les
autorisations d'exploiter et nous
les bâtons dans les roues je ne sais pas
si c'est comme cela qu'il faut l'appeler
mais l'administration
n'osent pas je vais le dire honnêtement
n'ose pas franchir le pas les
municipalités notre municipalité est
très frileuse elle n'est pas opposée
elle est bien consciente elle aussi elle
a des elle est consciente que ces
énergies renouvelables sont utiles pour
le pays mais voilà il y a une
incompréhension je pense de beaucoup de
services et beaucoup de personnes pour
faire avancer ces dossiers merci Nicolas
vous le constatez le marcéno ce que
vient de décrire des freins
effectivement vont on le voit bien sur
la méthanisation il faut qu'on se mette
d'accord d'ailleurs au niveau de la
société on veut sortir de la dépendance
au pétrole on veut sortir de la
dépendance au gaz
tout le monde veut bien mais pas chez
soi donc c'est vrai que c'est une
difficulté je dis moi qui vit à Londres
si je peux dire en Loir-et-Cher de la
centrale nucléaire de Saint-Laurent donc
en notre part du risque si je peux dire
et si tant que le riz soit très grand
mais donc ça c'est une vraie difficulté
parce qu'on serait pas dans cette
situation y compris la situation qu'on a
décrit d'un point de vue énergétique si
on était moins dépendant des autres et
qu'on le produisait nous-mêmes nos
énergies en particulier nous énergies
renouvelables donc on est en train il y
a un projet de loi sur les énergies
renouvelables qui vise à essayer
d'assouplir un certain nombre de
procédures à faciliter les choses puis
il y a un troisième sujet moi je pense
qu'il faut qu'on arrive à travailler
avec les agriculteurs il faut qu'on
arrive à expliquer aux citoyens ce que
sont les projets et quand ils sont
installés globalement on voit bien que
les nuisances sont très faibles très
marginales et que c'est bien pour tout
le monde pour l'agriculteur y compris
pour le territoire donc on a besoin
d'essayer d'expliquer on manque
peut-être de process et de méthodes pour
essayer de mieux expliquer sur le
territoire en tout cas aux gens de bonne
foi qui qui peuvent comprendre des
arguments qui sont des arguments là
aussi de mon sens en tout cas on a
accumulé bien dû retard alors crise
énergétique on vient de l'évoquer crise
climatique cette fois les Inconnus vous
allez voir se multiplient dans
l'équation
nous allons tout de suite filer en
Touraine pour rejoindre Jean-Yves
Chauvot journaliste à terre de Touraine
c'est hebdomadaire des agriculteurs des
éleveurs et des vignerons d'un vrai
Loire vous êtes en direct avec nous
depuis notre studio de Tours ces
questions de transition écologique et
est-ce qu'elles sont vraiment au cœur
des préoccupations des agriculteurs vous
qui êtes H24 avec eux
c'est le concret des agriculteurs ou pas
à pas il sait de s'adapter à chacune des
évolutions le constat de la profession
économiste agriculture et puis
nombreuses années sur ce thème
pragmatique en termes de transition
plutôt que le mot changement il parle
plutôt d'adaptation 1 pour réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre et de
gérer les nouvelles conditions
climatiques donc pour s'adapter un des
outils c'est la sélection génétique on
note que la France se bat au niveau
européen pour que les nouvelles
techniques notamment Christ K9 fils est
utilisé sans être bloquée par une
réglementation
OGM qui est obsolète par contre le sujet
d'actualité à Bruxelles c'est la volonté
du commissaire européen d'imposer une
réduction de 30% des produits
phytosanitaires
ça nous interroge les agriculteurs et
vont s'adapter au niveau aux conditions
climatiques pour utiliser le moins
possible de produits en 2022 en vigne et
vergée que ça soit en bio ou en
conventionnel il y a pas eu de
traitement parce que il y avait pas
d'humidité pas de maladie par contre cet
automne
cette réflexion et cette observation
à la sagacité de marcénot vous les
sentez vous les sentez concernés ces
agriculteurs français il y a plusieurs
sujets le dérèglement climatique le
changement climatique qui produit ce
qu'on a dit sur les questions d'accès à
l'eau de sécheresse il produit des
questions d'adaptation des des de ce que
nous plantons à ceux dérèglement
climatique la sécheresse d'abord le
réchauffement ensuite par ailleurs des
maladies qui se développent plus ou qui
se développent moins selon le type de
territoire et le type de climatologie
que nous avons de se dire
oui il a été décidé le gouvernement
français soutien l'idée de sortir d'un
certain nombre de produits
phytosanitaires parce que je pense que
c'est une exigence collective que nous
devons avoir alors c'est pas une c'est
une chose de le dire à cette table après
le deuxième chose que nous disons c'est
un au niveau européen de pas
d'interdiction sans que on ne cherche et
on ne trouve des solutions ça nécessite
de mettre des moyens sur la recherche
parfois c'est le changement de pratique
c'est une manière différente de conduire
à son exploitation et parfois ça vient
d'être dit et je pense que faut qu'on
aille résolument dans cette direction
c'est le nouvel technique qu'on a en
termes de génomique qui ne sont pas du
tout liés à la question des OGM qui est
pas du tout la même chose c'est mon
travail sur la même plante mais on
essaie de faire en accéléré ce que la
nature aurait peut-être fait en 10000 ou
20000 ans mais nous n'avons pas 20000
ans devant nous et donc ça permet
d'accélérer les processus et les
processus de transition et de donner des
solutions agriculteurs on a il y a
beaucoup d'espoir sur ces techniques on
va avoir un débat au niveau européen
pour donner un calendrier dans les dans
leur 23 qui permettra je pense de
d'ouvrir la voie de ces techniques qui
sont très prometteuses vous tendez la
perche justement parce qu'il y a le
climat qui modifie l'environnement mais
il est pas le seul responsable il y a
l'action de l'homme également vous
parliez justement à l'instant de tout ce
que l'on peut et pendre étendre dans les
dans les champs sur les cultures est-ce
qu'on peut quand même imaginer qu'un
jour on aura on aurait une agriculture
complètement propre et verte on a avancé
sur le griposate surtout ça mais on
avançait sur un certain nombre de sujets
mais reconnaissons que la stabilisation
des rendements et le fait qu'on est
moins d'un coup elle est aussi à
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires ça a permis de nous
garantir aussi une souveraineté
alimentaire après la révolution de la
mécanisation agricole s'est produit là
ils ont été ils ont été faits ils ont
été très utiles pour assumer notre
souveraineté en terme quantitatif
désormais on est dans une troisième
révolution qui est la révolution des
techniques ça a été dit à l'instant sur
les techniques les NBT ou le NGT comme
on les appelle les techniques de
biocontrôle donc on a besoin de faire
une troisième révolution qui
garantissent la production en quantité
en mode de dérèglement climatique et par
ailleurs qui garantit ce qu'on peut
sortir d'un certain nombre de produits
phytosanitaires mais tout ça la vérité
le grief qu'on fait parfois à
l'agriculture la société avait acté le
principe d'avoir des l'alimentation en
quantité et à bas prix et donc c'est
aussi cette réflexion là qu'il faudra
porter mais je suis sûr qu'on peut y
arriver il un certain nombre de secteurs
je pense par exemple sur le maïs les
techniques d'hybridation fait qu'on a
grandement avancé compris sur moins de
d'utilisation de produits
phytosanitaires et sur des hybrides qui
ont beaucoup besoin de beaucoup moins
d'eau donc c'est possible simplement il
faut il faut il faut qu'on bouleverse
les choses et pour cela on a besoin
d'appuyer la recherche merci en tout cas
Jean-Yves Chauveau de nous avoir conduit
à cette réflexion merci beaucoup
pour terminer notre entretien j'aimerais
aller il nous reste deux minutes 50
j'aimerais bien qu'on aille sur le champ
purement politique et que vous nous
donniez votre point de vue votre
ressenti sur le moment
alors ça vous a pas échappé Emmanuel
Macron connaît un second mandat qui ne
ressemble en rien on peut dire ça comme
ça ou précédent est-ce que Marc fenou
vous sentez le président de la
République tendu agacé parfois
et ça lui ferait commettre quelques
erreurs pas du tout c'est pas du tout le
sujet alors il peut être comme tout le
monde parfois tendu ou agacé le sujet
dans lequel est né c'est qu'on a une
majorité relative à l'Assemblée
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas une
majorité absolue ça porte des exigences
particulières qui sont celles d'essayer
de trouver d'autres acteurs dans le
Parlement qui puissent voter avec nous
un certain nombre de textes parce que
moi ça me paraît un élément important et
déterminant dans la crise que nous
traversons la question n'est pas de
savoir si on est dans la majorité ou
dans l'opposition dans la crise que nous
traversons la question est de savoir si
on résout les problèmes des gens la
question énergétiques les questions
qu'on a évoqué de transmission agricole
les questions qu'on a évoqué de
souveraineté question de crise
énergétique pour l'ensemble de citoyens
c'est des questions qui dépassent les
clivage alors après il faut trouver des
il faut trouver des partenaires qui soit
en capacité assez compliqué parce que la
négociation est extrêmement compliquée
c'est de trouver des gens qui quoi qu'en
étant dans l'opposition se mettent dans
la situation où ils auraient été dans la
majorité où ils auraient été à gouverner
la preuve de s'opposer on en est le
gouvernance jamais on en est où elisaban
Elizabeth borne pardon à dégainer 5 fois
déjà le 49.3 bah oui la grande question
c'est est-ce que il faut dissoudre
l'Assemblée mais qu'est-ce que ça doit
monter le 49-3 que il y avait pas une
majorité pour voter le budget mais qui
avait pas une majorité pour proposer une
alternative à ce budget parce
qu'effectivement parce que d'un banc à
l'autre de l'assemblée des deux bancs
extrêmes de l'Assemblée en fait personne
n'est d'accord donc il suffit pas d'être
simplement contre le gouvernement faut
faire des propositions et en fait ils
sont radicalement opposés sur les
solutions donc nous sommes le point
d'équilibre de la société c'est pour ça
que c'est important qu'on puisse avancer
sur un certain nombre de textes merci
infiniment Marc feno d'avoir répondu à
mes questions